I'm so looking forward to the draft
Peter it's funny wasn't that long ago
that the NFL treated Las Vegas like the
bubonic plague they wouldn't talk about
it it didn't even exist there's no way
we're doing business with Las Vegas
member Tony Romo was gonna have a
fantasy football convention there in a
property that wasn't a casino just
happened to be owned by a casino and
located in Las Vegas and they said no
you can't do it and now open arms
because there's plenty of open wallets
in Las Vegas a team a Super Bowl
eventually and inevitably and the draft
next year not next year this year in
April the fountains of the Bellagio will
be the red carpet and I'm gonna take
them out by boat they're gonna shut down
the strip and did you ever think Peter
the draft would become what it is now I
mean when I saw this yesterday I said
I'm on the verge of being a get off my
lawn guy about this I'm on the verge of
being very 62 years old when I see this
but the more I thought of it I just said
yeah you know it's the NFL putting an
event on in primetime and wanting to
make the people who watch The Bachelor
watch the draft that's what this is it's
all about the rating it's all about the
spectacle and when I saw that I said who
cares you know when you think about it
just let it happen
sit back let it happen watch your team
drew the funniest thing about this
absolute funniest thing the Cincinnati
Bengals the most dyed-in-the-wool 1950s
franchise in all of sports is going to
be the star of the show and Joe burrow
is going to go up on some sort of
gondolas oh he's gonna walk up there and
they're cameras gonna flash to Mike
Brown who will be vomiting in a pail @
Bengals draft headquarters in Cincinnati
it really is amazing though when you
think about what the NFL has done with
the product that is football and turned
it into this larger-than-life event
that's one thing because there's
substance behind the sizzle right when
the NFL Films crew slows down the
no kind of wafting toward the ground and
the guys running in John for Senate
there's substance there there's a
football game that people care about
what they've done with the draft is even
more remarkable because at its core it's
nothing they could do it by text message
right they used to do it in a
smoke-filled conference room in a hotel
all of this other stuff that they have
built up around it is meaning of this is
all premise Don selling hope to football
fans who want to see who their new
players are gonna be and they have taken
that and they've rubbed it and polished
it and it's grown and it's grown and
it's grown into something that no one
would have ever envisioned it would be
and frankly if they hadn't had a
scheduling conflict at Radio City Music
Hall seven or eight years ago it never
would have become this Roadshow that has
caused it to mushroom into an event that
is almost on par Peter with the Super
Bowl it's different altogether but it's
hot when you know what's the second
biggest event of the year for the NFL
it's the Super Bowl number one and the
draft is number two the reason why it is
so big I mean you look for instance at
fans in Cleveland and I was in Cleveland
you know when in 2018 for that draft and
I was there when basically the Sanford
the Cleveland Browns picked Baker
Mayfield and I went to a draft party and
I guess there were ten or twelve
thousand people at this draft party
downtown and that is what the draft is
Mike it sells hope in Cleveland this
year it's gonna sell hope in Miami in
Washington in all these different places
and so if your season is over in middle
of November and your and your season is
a lost cause what are you gonna start to
think about you're gonna start to think
about the draft so it's looking forward
it's the building of anticipation you
get the combine you get everything and
you can't wait for the draft and now
that's the reason why it's become so big
and why the NFL now is trying to
capitalize not just on football fans but
this is the first time where I ever said
it's different hey we're gonna have the
background of the
rocky statue in Philadelphia now it's
going to be such a spectacle that people
are gonna have to turn it to tune into
it to say what is this actually gonna
look like in Vegas and it's going to get
harder and harder as this thing
continues to grow for the NFL to get
people to not realize in November in
December when their teams are out of it
that it's actually in their interest if
you know you're not going to make the
playoffs it's in your interest to not
win games because the higher you are on
that pecking order the bigger deal your
team is for this event that is becoming
the biggest thing other than the Super
Bowl and there's there's a dichotomy
between
that end of season football and the
draft and it's going to be harder and
harder to keep the two separate as the
draft gets bigger and bigger so
fascinating times it did I tell you what
I haven't gone in a long time I may have
to go to Las Vegas for this year's draft
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports